las imágenes de rayos x son como fotos
del interior del cuerpo sin embargo
también se pueden hacer videos de rayos
x se hacen durante un procedimiento
llamado
fluoroscopia uno de los motivos por los
que su médico le puede pedir que se
realice un examen de fluoroscopia es
para averiguar si usted padece ciertas
enfermedades como problemas en el tracto
digestivo otro de los motivos por los
que su médico puede pedirle que se haga
una fluoroscopia es para realizar un
procedimiento por ejemplo una punción
espinal por último otro motivo podría
ser para localizar e identificar un
objeto extraño en su
cuerpo hay varios tipos de equipos para
realizar una
fluoroscopia se puede fijar un
fluoroscopio en una habitación blindada
especial o bien puede tratarse de un
equipo portátil que se puede mover hacia
donde esté usted si es necesario también
puede puede utilizarse una máquina para
tomografía computarizada o tc como un
fluoroscopio para ver cortes
transversales del cuerpo a medida que se
toman las imágenes antes de realizar un
procedimiento de fluoroscopia es posible
que le den una sustancia de contraste
puede ser en una bebida Una pasta una
píldora o una
inyección durante el procedimiento
estará acostado o de pie en una mesa de
rayos x se dirigirá un tubo de rayos x a
la parte del que se va a examinar luego
un as de rayos x pasará a través de la
parte del fluoroscopio que enfoca el As
únicamente hacia la zona del cuerpo que
se estudia esto ayuda a reducir la
exposición a los rayos x una vez que el
As pase a través del cuerpo se
convertirá en un video que se podrá ver
en una pantalla si se le dio una
sustancia de contraste esto hará que las
estructuras se destaquen mejor en la
pantalla Si tiene alguna pregunta hable
con su
médico
i